hello everyone and welcome to a really
really wild game that does not end the
way
you think it would end uh i didn't think
i'd be posting any videos today but i
saw this
comment by a gentleman named john suits
he said hey man you should cover this
game where both the grand masters
miss mate into and i'm a big fan of
these cases of double blindness
we've mentioned a few of them on this
channel so far
uh and it's always incredible when this
happens and these are not
just any players these are the the first
two gentlemen ever to be awarded the the
grand master title
when the grand master title was first
awarded in the 1950
and las los albo here uh hungarian grand
master was a
three times member of the of the
candidates tournament
and uh in his last candidate tournament
he came very very close to winning it he
shared third place with some
very respectable gentlemen and samuel
rushevsky also
a legend who does doesn't really need
any introduction
also a member of the candidates
tournament himself and uh once a member
of the
uh wheelchair championship tournament as
it was played in those days
uh but uh just uh give you a a little a
bit of an idea of how strong these guys
are and this is a game from the 1953
uh international tournament in city uh
the tournament that
i said we were going to cover completely
i even got braunstein's book on the
tournament
that was some year ago i think but then
you know a lot of things happened and i
never got around to it
but we did uh covered uh the two first
games uh from the book and they were
like really really amazing
so i do hope to return to this
tournament at some point maybe after the
morphe saga but okay
just to give you an idea of how strong
these two gentlemen are
uh and also samuel rushevsky he uh he
won i think
um the the u.s championship eight times
the same as bobby fischer so
that's pretty pretty pretty awesome now
getting to this game
uh we're not going to dwell too long on
anything because i know what we're all
here to see
how can two of these uh really really
strong players
uh miss such an idea so this is what
happened now zabo opens
with d4 we have knight to f6 c4
e6 knight to f3 and of course d5 the
queen's gambit declined is on the board
we have knight c3
and c5 now striking in the center
we have captures on d5 captures on d5
with the knight and
now e3 so this is still standard theory
today
uh also a very much played line still in
2020 so knight to c6 and here bishop to
d3 continuing development
and nowadays bishop to e7 is the go-to
move uh
as it is it is uh suggested mostly by
today's top engines
uh but in those days we have knight
captures on c3 and okay be captures in
bishop to e7 now
uh and here we have queen to c2 and it
is as of move 9 that the disposition has
never been reached again
so it's a very nice setup preventing
black from castling as bishop captures
on h7 comes
so so instead of castling of course g6
is played
and h4 g6 is now a target and the zabo
wants to attack it with h5
must open the position and start an
attack against black's king so it's
always incredibly
dangerous for reshevsky to at the castle
here so instead
we have h5 by black and now rook to b1
again making it a bit difficult for
black to develop
as just captures here would be uh would
if you develop the bishop just capture
some b7
so rook to ba defending and now bishop
to e4
again with the threat of just captures
with check if you recapture then the
rook on b8 falls as the bishop is
still undeveloped so queen to c7
developing while defending the rook now
bishop captures on c6 isn't really
anything and the
white castles here and here bishop
to d7 uh still not eager to castle for
example
if a castle here bishop captures on g6
is very dangerous
just captures queen captures and g6 is
coming and could be
could be very dangerous uh so here black
instead just continues development
bishop to d7
and now white starts the attack d5
attacking the knight and
threatening uh to to character on e6 so
we have e captures on d5
bishop captures on d5 and now uh bishop
to f6
uh i'm not gonna tell you uh too much
about the position because uh
i might spoil the missed opportunity for
you so i'm just gonna ask you in the
critical
critical
position what uh what was supposed to be
played here
so here bishop to f6 uh preparing bishop
back to g7 so black and finally castle
and knight to g5 now white puts extreme
pressure on black's position
because it's uh well it's very easy to
go wrong here
uh you could uh you could capture the
knight and it's the the safest way to go
however uh black decided to defend the
f7 square by playing knight to d8 now
df7 square is defended
and you want to play bishop to g7 and
castle
uh as soon as possible so here white
continues with c4
uh adds more defense to the bishop here
and also opens up this diagonal he wants
to play bishop to d2 to
challenge this bishop and to maybe get
get his queen
on this on this diagonal so here bishop
to c6
black now uh offers a trade of dark
square bishops but now comes
knight to e4 bishop to b2 is incredibly
strong here but
that's uh besides the point as this is a
video
for uh you know showing missed
opportunities
uh we have knights to e4 now threatening
to pick up the bishop here with
check and bishop back to g7 and only now
bishop to b2
threatening the bishop on g7 and here
finally we have castles by black
and now comes almost the moment we've
all been waiting for
knight to f6 check and here the black
king is in check
so what do you do here well the only
thing you can do here is king to h8
there is no other move so this is the
only move possible for black here
however well not possible but playable
but however black played bishop captures
on f6 here
and now feel free to pause the video and
find this
idea that we're talking about here while
i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations as i'm sure you
know
what we're talking about uh since i
asked you to pause the video and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
it's queen captures on g6 and that's all
there is
it's mate on the next move regardless of
what black does you could cover up with
the bishop but the bishop already covers
the g7 square so just queen captures and
g7 is checkmate
and even if you move the king let's say
king to h8 then comes
bishop captures on f6 again mating one
so from this position after this bishop
captures on f6
uh there's nothing for black to do
bishop captures is just a mating two for
for white and it's incredible but black
missed it and uh
zabo believed rashevsky that this was
actually okay and he
instead played bishop captures on f6
and you might think wow this is crazy
it's incredible that something like this
happens
uh in a game between uh two such strong
grand masters who were you know both
of them members of of the candidates
tournament no less
uh however that's not all for this game
because
uh well the drama will continue so here
we have bishop captures on d5
black decides to trade in the center c
captures giving white a very nice pass
pawn and queen to d6 now blockading the
pawn
we have queen to c3 makes sense black no
longer has a dark square bishop you want
to
have your queen and bishop on this
diagonal maybe some bishop to h8 ideas
will be possible followed by queen to g7
you never know so here black goes queen
captures on d5 just
uh capturing a pawn in cold blood but it
is the strongest move in the position
however
here of course if you go bishop to h8
the threat and checkmate uh
black defense would knight to e6 because
the queen
vacated the square and now the knight
can easily defend against checkmate
so here we have rook after d1 attacking
the queen
and now queen to f5 it's uh it's kind of
important to avoid the e6 square because
you kind of want to
leave that for the knight so if any
bishop to h8 action happens you always
have knight to a6
however here zabo played e4 and it's uh
well it's just a beautiful pawn
sacrifice because
rashevsk already grabbed the d5 pawn and
now zabo is offering yet another pawn
and the queen captures on e4 is the
absolute strongest move here
i mean you you grab another pawn and
it's uh hard for
uh hard for white to to do anything
because after you capture it
like there are no ideas like rook
captures here to to get rid of the the
defender of the mate because the rook on
b1 would be hanging with
check so it's very hard to to even
imagine what zabo had in mind in this
position when he pushed e4 however
uh it was enough to trick uh roshewski
here because he played queen to e6 and
queen to e6 is a
is a what move uh because you've taken
away a very important square from this
knight so here
uh zabo immediately goes bishop to g7
and now there's a problem
not only are you threatening to pick up
the rook uh there there are also uh uh
some other very
very important threats uh so here uh we
have
b6 uh you could move the rook like uh
you could move the rogue rook to e8 but
what uh
white had in mind here is just bishop to
h6 threatening checkmate
and now to prevent this you would have
to go queen e5 and then after the trade
let's say captures captures bishop f4 is
enough to win the game as you will
win uh the rook on e5 black will have to
defend if you don't want to lose a clean
rook so just captures capture so white
is up the exchange
and has an easily winning game however
after this bishop to g7 move we have b6
by rashevsky and now uh well i i think i
already
said too much but just in case uh feel
free to pause the video and
win the game for for zabo here while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it uh congratulations on again
spotting
an instant resigner for black and even
greater congratulations if you also
found the mating 2 on the previous
puzzle
but for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's bishop to h6
it's incredible because it threatens
checkmate on g7
and after the only only way to defend
this is to play f6 but now comes uh the
problem
the rooks are not connected for black
and the g6 pawn is weak
and now comes queen to g3 and that's it
you either get queen captures on g6
check followed by queen g7 checkmate
or black has to defend the g6 pawn and
then you just pick up a clean rook
so not only have both of them missed the
mating two in this game but they also
missed
this idea so the these these two
gentlemen are incredibly strong chess
players and both of them
uh members of of candidate tournaments
at some point uh and uh for those of you
who are maybe just joining us
in the candidate tournament you decide
who will be the challenger
uh to the world champion so these are
incredibly strong players
uh so what actually happened in the game
after this b6 move
uh azabu did not find bishop to h6
rather uh bishop captures on f8 was
played so aruk was captured with king
captures on f8 and now even though white
is up the exchange
uh black dot black is up upon and for
some reason
uh they decided to to agree to a draw
here even though
white white is a material white could
push for more here i guess
maybe at some point uh zabo realized
what he what he
what he did that he missed maybe he
realized he missed the mating too maybe
he realized he missed this second idea
uh so maybe he just wasn't interested in
this game anymore
and uh he he over the reserve scared raw
uh
if anyone knows who offered to draw uh
to who here uh do share in the comments
i
i will definitely pin it and give it a
heart so everyone can see
but yeah after this king to h8 move the
players agree to a draw
and uh well like i said it is playable
queen to h it doesn't really do all that
much the king is perfectly fine on e7
uh and also the knight is nicely
defended so not not much for the white
queen to do there
but you could play a move like f4 you
could uh you know
slow play it and try to try to gain some
advantage today of course you don't
resign this you you play this
on but i'm sure zabo realized what he
did and
he he decided to offer a draw uh but
yeah
uh thanks uh uh thanks incredibly uh a
lot
jon suits for recommending this game
because i don't know when
we are going to cover the entire
tournament so we would probably reach it
at some point but
you know it's good to reach it now and
it it's an incredible idea like i said
i'm a big fan of these
cases of double blindness where both the
players missed such and i
such a well this was a rather simple
idea
uh but you just don't expect uh
rosherski to make
a mistake like this and then you just
ignore it and you know you don't think
it's possible for
for a player of chef's excalibur to to
make a mistake like this
but yeah like i said first uh they miss
uh uh simple mate in two and then
again an idea like bishop to h6 so this
game is just uh you know
a treasure house of missed opportunities
uh but yeah uh once again thank you for
suggesting this uh
i would like to thank dave neve jimmy
hernandez uh
anderson rojaramos bryce foster and
nicole church for a contribution to my
channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the chess world
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day